here's what's going on at the movies The  BFG offers fantastic fantasy fare for  the whole family as Steven Spielberg  brings Roald Dahl's classic tale about a  young girl and a Big Friendly Giant to  life  Collective Tarzan swings into theaters  for an action-packed adventure that  finds the now civilized Tarzan called  back to protect his jungle home  the purge has to come to an end in the  third installment of the horror  franchise the purge election year  follows Leo Barnes as he attempts to  protect the presidential candidate who  promises to end purge night  and finally let's find out what's hot in  theaters this weekend with this week's  fantasy patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket